let's jump to the first story i tweeted
this
stephen crowder has been suspended from
twitter after saying he can confirm that
people voted at addresses that do
not exist he stated the same in a video
so
you may have seen the video it came up
earlier this morning
he uh did this on his morning show he
literally
sent people to addresses let me see if i
can pull up like a screenshot
trying to find it there we go wait we
just lost it so there we go
is that let me see i'll just play a
little clip from this from his bit so
you can see they're holding up the
newspaper they go and they find these
like
well this is just like it looks like a
house here we go empty parking lots
one of them that was really interesting
was that he they're holding up a
newspaper and they show empty parking
lot
and apparently there was supposed to be
an apartment number 409 now i'll put it
very very simply
crowder claimed all of this on youtube
he's
he straight up said that he can prove it
and he will testify
under penalty of perjury that this is
true these addresses do not exist
i'm simply saying he's saying it i'm
showing you what i saw
it looks compelling i wouldn't need to
actually check the addresses because i
got to be honest
i'm just seeing crowder's video but i
don't think he'd go when he'd make this
up
the crazy thing is crowder did not say
he actually clarified this
very very clearly that he's not saying
this is evidence of any you know bigger
scheme or anything like that just that
they found evidence of addresses that
don't exist that's all it is
it doesn't mean the entire election is
bunker anything like that but they
should certainly be looked into right
that's well that's as as far as any
reasonable person would go
until you you get to like courts or
adjudication twitter
took down locked his account because he
tweeted this
that to me is absolutely insane because
he actually has
video showing this so he did put up an
article on his uh
on his website and he says proof we went
to fake voter addresses he
he talks quite a bit about it but that's
the gist of the story
you should check out his bit too because
it was pretty funny where he kind of
talks about mike lindell having this bad
information
believing his dominion stuff and i was
getting sued over it but he also
mentions that
you know mike lindell has this
documentary called absolute proof
and crowder did the segment called like
absolute proof 100
fair trade definitive and all that stuff
so
i actually i think you know considering
mike you're a lawyer i'm curious uh
what your thoughts are because we we
should we should definitely talk about
the supreme court as well
and and pennsylvania yeah the so that
was another
reason that i clash so much with the
first time trump voters
is they were coming they were saying all
this dominion stuff and i'm like no
that's not how it works
there was no shootout like i'm like why
am i the debunker
my job you mean in germany they claimed
that the servers were being airlifted
it's crazy satellites in italy like
someone was telling me that i'm like
huh are you kidding me and i hate doing
that because
trump supporters are so attacked on
every side
the last thing i want to do is shoot
inside the bunker
but i don't want people to believe
things that are wrong and the problem
here
to tie to that point with crowder there
was a guy you guys would know his name i
forget it right now but
he went through and did an analysis like
this of
nursing homes halfway houses other areas
and by the way i'm not making any claims
but it showed like oh wow so there's a
hundred votes came out of here some of
them are supposedly mail drops
and there were a lot of things that you
could look at like crowder looked at
but instead everybody now thinks the
narrative is that
a few goofballs on the internet or in
the case of mike lindell successful
entrepreneur who believes what he said
which as a lawyer makes that a really
interesting case because
usually as you know to suit someone for
defamation you have to show actual
malice
was malice doesn't mean that you didn't
like the person malice means that you
didn't actually believe what you were
saying
or you entertained doubts about what you
were saying like that mike lindell knew
what he was saying was false yeah or
dude believes at all yeah he believes
he's like hell yeah you're suing me this
is amazing i can't wait to see you guys
in court
so as a lawyer thinking this is actually
uh a newer area of law like how do you
actually get him for defamation but
the problem is that became the whole
narrative of it where now
mark elias and other people say oh the
trump people filed 100 lawsuits none of
them went anywhere
this is proof there was nothing there
and it's like no they they found like a
couple
one of them was the pennsylvania one
that didn't get heard and when you look
at the issues
that they tried to resolve they were
quite interesting or if you look at the
evidence that was presented
that crowder is presenting it's quite
interesting it's the kind of thing that
makes you
maybe you should think about but that's
been completely hidden in the squid ink
of this dominion stuff and all the yeah
the weird
conspiracy i'm rarely called some of the
conspiracy theory but there's no other
word for that
if i if i had to have a conspiracy it
would be that the conspiracies are the
conspiracy to derail the actual
conspiracy
you see you see what it did there no i
believe that no i i i
i'm not saying it's true i'm just i'm
joking no but i actually vacillate
between
because there's some people that are so
they lead people down such a bad path
that you think in life you get lucky
you're gonna have some wins and you're
just a loss after loss after loss
so i'm a little co-intel pro conspiracy
orientated where i do think a lot of
people do
set you up well you don't need to have a
conspiracy here we have cass sunstein
obama's information czar that literally
wrote the playbook on disinformation and
he talked about creating fake
conspiracies to make anyone questioning
government look
insane and he did this specifically with
a lot of family members and rescue
workers in new york city after the 2001
events so
uh that you know he he wrote it in his
own bylines in his own published paper i
asked him about it he denied even
writing it even though it's
it's still up there on the internet uh
it was published
in one of um scientific journals
that he wrote about how to combat and
fight this information and one of his
ways was
infiltrating groups in real life and
online and making them look
crazy and that's and that's what i kept
complaining about when these people come
out with these really absurd
conspiracies about like
cia agents storming german servers and
then like italy and whatever i'm like
who cares
who cares we've got a constitutional
legal battle happening in pennsylvania
that's more important and could have a
bigger result
well they had you had credible testimony
under oath in the michigan hearings i
actually watched the hearings
and my jaws were dropping you had
credible normal decent people
providing eyewitness testimony of what
they saw but nobody watched the hearings
the pennsylvania hearing that didn't
really get covered the michigan one
which i found quite persuasive
wasn't really covered so now when people
think of
you know i don't want fraud of the
election
then that's what they think is all this
really kooky stuff when actually there
were issues there were issues with
people changing the rules midstream
which is what happened in pennsylvania
right where as you aptly tweeted if they
change the rules and you sue they go
well you know i'm standing nothing bad
has happened
and then the rules are applied and then
you see when they go well it's too late
now it's moved
right it's like i said that's 22. yeah
that's that's a horrifying precedent
and that's basically what we got with
you know clarence thomas and claire's
thomas
and his dissent he said we did we failed
to you know
rule on this before and now we're not
going after what are the rules like no
one's gonna know no one's gonna have any
confidence in the system
right and that was a legitimate legal
issue that was a legitimate case that
should have been heard
but the supreme court justices i think
kavanaugh
and bear i think they would have heard
it had january 6th not happened
and moreover had there not been all of
these the linwood stuff and all this
other
things that people brought up is you
don't want to be caught up in that net
of here's all the kooks and the kooks
are in the net
and now you're a supreme court justice
and you're in you're in the net with
them
you're i hear you but man talk about
cowards
i i wouldn't care i don't care okay well
i'll make the case for them then i'll
make the case for john roberts as an
institutionalist
the way that john roberts would say if
you're being candid is that
the this is how you learn it in federal
courts and law school and
is the supreme court is a co-equal
branch of government just like the
congress and just like the executive
branch
they had to fight and scrape for all
their legitimacy and all their power
the supreme court was not powerful at
all actually before the war in court
in the 1950s so what do they have they
don't have guns
they don't have a budget they don't have
any real power all their power is soft
power
right so if you're going to enter an
area that
where there's such a narrative that's
already set so strongly
as there is now with this election stuff
then you're attacking or you're going to
make the institution weaker by doing it
now you would come back and say why you
don't agree with that and i would agree
with you
but that would be what john roberts
would argue so when people talk about
john roberts
a lot of um conservatives people
especially he's an institutionalist so
fundamentally he
even comey was the same way comey is it
was
way was crooked so he's maybe not the
right example but
the idea is you protect the institution
the institutional supreme court that
means you have to pick your battles
and if you're going through the calculus
you're thinking yeah you know do we
really want to get involved in all this
stuff when there's
talk of insurrection it could be that
they it's a fight they knew they weren't
going to win anyway so they said it was
moot
yeah exactly and and some people call it
a cop-out which is a fair point
other people will say that you have to
protect the soft power of the supreme
court
and there's a fair point that because a
lot of our institutions have lost
soft power when you say that that he
would fear that it's going to weaken the
institution
is that it will weaken the perception of
the institution through the media
well and yeah through the collective
hive minds so the idea is that
the supreme court can't cut anyone's
budget but congress if they wanted to
could cut the law clerk budget there's
all these different ways that they could
they can mess with them
the supreme court if they want to have
an order enforced they can't have the
fbi
kick down the door and take power their
rule is by reason
their rule is by soft power their rule
is by people saying
that's the supreme court opinion that
really means something
now after bush versus gore you got to
remember if we hadn't had 9 11
bush versus gore would have been four
years of bush being the orange man
the the institution of the court the
soft power of the court had declined
significantly because it was a
close opinion on partisan lines and it
was a little dodgy even by
by my assessment of it so you had a loss
of institutional power
a loss of saw power the idea that this
is a supreme court this is an edict you
should follow it because
ultimately if the supreme court issues a
ruling that an executive officer doesn't
like
the president could just say well i
don't know who cares right there was a
believe was andrew jackson who said the
supreme court has issued their ruling
not let them enforce it that all that
historical background is swirling around
and it is fundamentally true if the
supreme court issued a ruling and trump
didn't want to follow it he could just
say we're just not going to
abide by this rule what are you going to
do i have my praetorian guard
so there there's a lot of conflict there
and
soft power is kind of an amorphous term
too which is how do people rule
well the supreme court they don't have
any hard power congress has hard power
right
they can want subpoena power well by
hard power i mean they can actually do
things to you like
you don't have a budget the lights
aren't going to work they can pass laws
making something a crime
right they have an enforcement mechanism
whereas like even the media
to put a different example the media has
no hard power soft power
as more people just said we don't really
care as elon musk
tells the washington post i don't care
i'm not going to answer your articles
and as more people say we like elon we
don't like the media who cares
the media doesn't have any power anymore
right the power is only in that
ability to shape public opinion the
ability that
oh this is in the new york times this
must be matter this must be true this is
how we're gonna live our lives
so that's the supreme court even though
it's a branch of government
elon's response was pretty telling today
because the washington post quoted him
as saying
quote give my regards to your puppet
masters when they asked him for an
interview so he didn't just like shun
them away he made sure to send them a
message
especially to the washington post which
is being seen more of an institutional
establishment kind of
paper of record for the intelligence
agencies i won't i won't do interviews
with any of these people i won't i
ignore them and honestly even in like
smaller independent and
you know whatever you know channels i i
won't do that for the most part either
there's very very few
anything i'll do with anyone else the
whole system is
is just man is a clown show to put it
mildly right and their soft powers
decline so here's what i mean by that is
it used to be that a hit piece would
actually kind of damage you right you
got it
you got written about it said bad things
people say ooh i don't know if i want to
talk to that person to be around that
person
and then it it changed the point where i
don't even respond
only kind of boomers like jordan
peterson responded hit pieces oh read
this mean thing they said about me
everybody else knows your people aren't
even going to read it 99 of them aren't
even going to read it first of all
the ones who do read it aren't even
going to believe it so even if the media
writes something about you critical
that's true
your own follower is going to say oh
they probably just made the whole thing
up the whole thing's fake
that that's a change though and that's
what i mean by the soft power the
ability to shape
narrative the ability to shape public
perception i i got to be honest if
that's
i heard you're saying and i understand
it and that sounds to me like the
supreme court is
a bunch of cowards they're weak they're
pathetic they have no real power anyway
and it sounds like you've got these
three branches of government where they
pretend the supreme court is co-equal
when in reality they're like the loser
kids in the in the corner of the
playground
and their only their only claim to power
is they're like that little kid in a
recess who would suck up to the teacher
is just crossing their fingers and
hoping you listen to them if they're not
actually going to stand up for anything
then what's the point of having in the
first place
well they would say that they're just a
check on government that checks should
be
used in exceptional circumstances and
under limited circumstances
that was the idea that's why when people
talk about judicial activism
they're talking about the court taking a
very active role as the warren country
oh there's a right to this there's a
right to this there's a right to that
there's a right to that
these rights are protected the other
rule or rather the other view of the
court is a more conservative one
jewish potentially not necessarily
politically which is that the supreme
court shouldn't get involved in this
kind of stuff so i'll give i give a
great example is
if donald if the senate had um convicted
trump
and trump had tried to sue in the
supreme court there's something called
the political question doctrine
which holds that they would just say
this isn't for us to decide this is a
political question so there's
things called abstention doctrines and
one of which is a little bit different
from standing but the idea of abstention
is
even when the supreme court has
jurisdiction they won't
hear the case under these various
doctrines so you're right in the sense
that they're
not the most powerful but somebody like
john roberts would
would maybe cheekily respond i agree
with you that's the point where we are
the little kids we're not the one who's
supposed to oh that's
that's that if if that were the case and
it sounds like it is
then that's mean serious trouble for
this country
it means there's no resolution to make
to serious disputes it means that the
conflict that has been escalating over
the past several years will have
no resolution your hope is that this
this council of
legal experts and elders can step in and
say
we've heard the arguments and we will
now be the tiebreaker or the referee in
this one
instead they said you've complained
you've actually brought up some
interesting arguments
shove it yeah i mean look look at the
way andrew cuomo treated the supreme
court
they told him they ruled his lockdown
orders were unconstitutional
he said i don't care i'm just going to
do new ones that don't apply to this
specific one
so you know seeing andrew cuomo do this
really kind of
signals that the supreme court is not
going to be your savior like many people
can i see like the supreme court is like
a lens that's focusing
the law for the american people to see
clearly and it's up to us as the people
to enforce what they can kind of show us
but
that's all they really do is pass
through ideas it's meaningless
well i i would say this though is if as
critical as i might be the supreme court
of federal judges especially in federal
courts
i would trust the federal judge if i had
to choose some kind of like gambit
do you trust this random member of
congress with your rights you trust the
president with your rights
trump or biden or do you trust a federal
judge with your rights i would trust the
federal judge
i think you'd be better off choosing a
partisan member of your tribe in a
political party
yeah but we're doing a rawlsy and veil
ignorance thing though we're saying that
you can't get to pick like
i would obviously you know choose if you
could choose the referee you can't but
if you're looking at just in terms of
the system i would still say the courts
are
better equipped and more likely to to
vindicate or care about individual
rights
and the flip side too is the january 6th
i mean if you're an adult and you watch
that you say that's a bad thing
you know but 9 11 9 11.
right we live in a childish world where
every adult can be like yeah this is bad
you know you need to suss out who is
doing what but we have to we're supposed
to basically pretend
which i say we off we live in like the
age of pretend which is oh my that was a
9 11.
holy cow event so it's this fake emotion
and the supreme court
they're sensitive to that the idea that
it's 911 but in a way it's worse than
911 because
the 911 terrorists all got pro bono
legal representation by the most elite
lawyers in the country
none of those elite lawyers are going to
do anything for these trump supporters
outside of that uh people who have been
detained in guantanamo bay
will get these very high prestigious pro
you know problems
donating their time but you get you get
you know uh
bernie bernice from oklahoma who's being
charged with two misdemeanors for
trespass
and a lot of them are and the lawyer's
like i'm not going anywhere near that
and what's worse about that is they're
being held
this is the thing where if you're a
lawyer you're like screaming on the
inside because
and federal court's a little different
than state there's something called the
federal sentencing guidelines varies
like mathematical
is it your first offense was it a
non-violent offense what did you
actually do when you get your like time
most of the indictments i've read are
bernice
some maga grandma you know read some
weird thing on the internet
showed up didn't know there was a riot
because she's just following the crowd
walks in oh hi everybody and she's just
smiling and thinks nothing happened
well that's trespass that's a day in
jail
maybe but they're being held without
bail
right so they're doing they're actually
going to do more time pre-trial it's
supposed to be the opposite because
you're presumed innocent
this is the scary thing about what we're
seeing right so there's some other
stories we
may get into a little bit like the fbi
seizing congressional phone records
saying that members of congress are now
suspects you've got naomi wolf she
originally went tucker carlson saying
totalitarian totalitarianism is here and
and we'll jump into those and
get into those in in fuller detail in a
second but what's scary is
that the democrats will not stop they
won't the republicans
are worthless republican leadership is
an oxymoron and they're basically just
like
you know democrats do your thing the
democrats are basically saying we will
use the most
insane interpretation of anything that
we saw we will use
every bit of power we have and the
republicans would never do that
they're too weak so the democrats are
going to start steamrolling people
people who there's some video where the
cops opened the door to the capitol and
people just walked in confused
confused and bewildered those people are
now facing serious jail time
then you have the year of riots where
people literally burn down buildings
what did merrick garland say well
well it's extremism because it happened
at night but it's terror because it was
during the day or something like that
i i understand going out there going
after like the electoral
college vote count is very very serious
but
don't you think burning down buildings
and destroying cities
and what the 19 plus dead directly from
the riots as well as the chaz
where they pumped for 10 minutes
hundreds of rounds into an suv with two
teenagers in it
these people shouldn't many of them be
facing jail time as well
well that but that's a quaint view of
american equality right will chamberlain
talks about
how the the media these people in dc
they're like the patrician class and
we're kind of like the peasant class
i i call it the new gym pro which is a
little absurd given you know what had
happened there but you know
it all starts a little bit early the
idea is like i know that i'm a second
class citizen
i just know it i accept it that's why
i'm not on the internet well why can't i
tweet out what would he because i can't
because i'm i'm not fully human to them
right i fully understand i might not
like it but i get it
so when you understand that if you're
perceived as a conservative right-wing
you are not a human being to these
people
then they don't care if your buildings
burn down they care that their capital
building which is by the way
taxpayer-funded as an american
i'm way more outraged that some mom
can't feed her kids
because her business was built down then
i care that something like
taxpayer-funded building is going to
have to be
prepared that's all taxpayer money
anyway but but that's a very
outdated archaic model of all of us
being equal as america no that's
i i agree and i say it all the time like
what's the point of me doing a video
where i'm like look at this double
standard duh we all know it
these these now i mean granted we're
seeing this really hilarious thing where
the new york times and slate
you know personnel are getting fired
they're they're losing that protection
as well so
i will say there's some optimism in that
regard that they're eating themselves
faster and faster
to the point where they might there
might just not be whatever it is they're
doing the establishment media the soft
power
will be going away well if all you do is
hypocrisy then yeah you're
you're like that's a conservative cliche
there's that meme here lies
conservatism and then the the headstone
says something like imagine if it were a
democrat
but there's this other uh lindsay
something or another i read all these
people on twitter don't even know their
names
but he said the idea is you're just
putting um
you're putting sand in the gears so the
idea is i know for a fact that it annoys
chris cuomo
and jake taper and these people they do
get annoyed now are they going to change
their minds are they going to be better
not really but it annoys them and
sometimes all you can do
as a second class citizen as somebody
who's essentially without
institutional power you can just annoy
these people a little bit and then you
have
you know in incidents like chris cuomo
where he melts down on a guy threatens
to throw a guy down the stairs and
you know he's completely losing it so
you know that you know that he's
bothered by it
that's sometimes all you can do and i
think that's worth doing but for someone
like you or other people like ben
shapiro or you look or just any anybody
with a big platform
when that's all i see in your time i'm
like oh my god
go do something especially when people
have money that's when i get really
triggered
like when it's trump campaign people
it's like okay you guys raised 250
million dollars post-election
to investigate whatever you're gonna
investigate why don't you take
i mean you know what it costs take 25
million dollars and
you could hire a full army investigative
reporter it's like oh well why doesn't
cnn cover this
i don't know why don't you hire 50
reporters though
they don't really care but no they don't
exactly that's the scam and that's where
i get into it with mega people because
you know what it costs i know what it
costs everybody here knows what it costs
so we're like look they got 250 million
dollars dude you're going to give them
more money
you are an idiot that's what i tell them
and people don't like to hear that but
they could take a million dollars and
hire
eight nine ten reporters i mean you
don't gotta give them six figures
hire 20 and give them all 40 something
thousand a year and people will do it
right now people have lost their jobs
you can find people to do this but
you're right they had 250 million
dollars
i don't think they actually really cared
more importantly i think trump cared
but people around him certainly did not
and weren't there to help him they were
there to extract as much as they could
from him
and well he fell for it i mean he fell
for it but
moreover the the problem that i had is
like the donors fell for it
i'm always like demand more of your
leaders i think that's where again i
differ from a lot of trump people is
the idea is like if you go to bed
tonight and you wake up you're not gonna
be like oh god i just had mike on my
show and he's tweeting
and bombs what indigestion you're never
gonna wake up with indigestion
that's how you should be if you're uh
if you're trump you should just realize
okay i don't want my people to wake up
with indigestion i know people like to
have a lot of fun
i know that we should keep it light i
know they like a little bit of trolling
but i don't want people just to wake up
with the complete case of
what you know what did i really do and
trump would kind of do that over and
over again and that's where he became
his own worst enemy or even stuff like
early on i i never liked was the beefing
with lebron james like you're president
now dude yeah you don't get to
you can be for lebron james in 2015.
2018 guess what you don't get to do that
anymore or slam dunking on rosie while
his supporters are being kicked off the
internet
there's a famous saying that there's a
meme about that says people who believe
in politicians think that strippers
actually like them
they don't politicians don't like you
either and a lot of them sadly are being
used for their personal benefit and
a lot of it is not being done for
yearbook well let's thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you